la central nuclear de Sa purilla ocupada
por las fuerzas rusas desde el pasado
mes de marzo es ahora propiedad de Rusia
según Vladimir Putin al firmar un
decreto el miércoles el presidente ruso
se apropió oficialmente las cuatro
regiones anexionadas el pasado viernes
tras unos referéndums de farsa por
occidente a raíz de esto el director
general del organismo internacional de
energía atómica aceleró su visita a kiev
con la que quiere discutir el
establecimiento de una zona de
protección alrededor de la central
nuclear más grande de Europa a primera
hora de la tarde el presidente ruso dejó
que confiaba en la estabilización de la
situación militar en los territorios
anexionados
Por supuesto suponemos que la situación
se estabilizará y podremos desarrollar
estas zonas de forma pacífica tras los
éxitos militares en el noreste en la
región de el ejército ucraniano continúa
su ofensiva en el sur en gerson donde
los combates siguen el ministro de
defensa ruso asegura que sus fuerzas
mantenen su posición y repelen los
ataques en otra parte del este en la
región de lugans un funcionario
ucraniano dijo que sus tropas habían
logrado progresos
podemos decir oficialmente que la
desocupación de la región de lubansk ha
comenzado ya se han liberado varias
localidades del ejército ruso de los
ocupantes rusos todos estos soldados
entienden que están derrotados pero para
el kremlin no hay duda a pesar de los
reveses sobre el terreno los territorios
han accionados seguirán siendo rusos
Esto no es una contradicción los
territorios han accionados serán rusos
para siempre serán reconquistados el
miércoles los estados miembros de la
Unión Europea votaron una nueva Ronda de
sanciones contra Rusia que incluyen más
restricciones en el comercio con Moscú
de productos siderúrgicos y tecnológicos
y un tope en el precio del petróleo para
las entregas de crudo ruso vía Europa